this December Netflix is cooking up a
buffet with a little something for
everyone with both exciting originals
and new blockbusters like Avengers
infinity war and that's just the
beginning he has a quick look at
everything good coming to Netflix in
December 2018 and the circus made a name
for himself as a motion-capture
juggernauts behind Gollum in the Lord of
the Rings and he's gone on to parlay
that particular scale into a long run
behind the camera and special effects of
some of the biggest blockbusters of the
era with Mowgli legend of the jungle
circus will again be heard and not seen
as both the director and the voice of
below this gritty origin story sees the
jungle boy Mowgli on a quest to discover
who he really is along the way he'll
face down not only the vicious Shere
Khan but also perhaps the greatest
threat of all humans look for it on
December 7th on screen gangster tales
have ranged in locale from old-world
Sicily to early 20th century London to
that most terrifying location of all
modern-day New Jersey but what about
Canada well good news bad blood is
storming the streets of Montreal with a
gritty dramatization of real-life crime
boss vito rizzuto after spending years
in prison watching his hard-won empire
fall to pieces before his eyes Rizzuto
gets released and sets out to retake his
territory and exact revenge and the
competing gangs who killed his son and
father check it out when the first
season premieres on December 7th
espionage and political intrigue are the
names of the game in this Australian
series that follows a small group of
spies working in the secretive central
Australian base Pine Gap a real location
playing gap weaves actual events into
fictional narrative lowering the line
between high-stakes drama and real-life
consequences although the series already
aired in Australia starting in October
2018 Pine Gap is set to hit Netflix
globally on December 7th with a first
season run of six episodes don't miss
her
Netflix's musical documentary series
remastered is tuning up for its third
entry and if it's anything like the
first - it's bound to hits all the right
notes in who killed Jam Master Jay
audiences we'll get an in-depth look at
the circumstances surrounding the
unsolved shooting that took the life of
the iconic hip hop DJ in 2007 take a
look when we mastered who killed Jam
Master Jay drops
December 7th there's a lot to love in
this high-stakes Australian series which
follows two strangers who accidentally
wind up in the middle of a criminal
conspiracy and find themselves on the
run from both the police and the bad
guys wanted packs its airtime with
comedy action and drama and leaves you
hungry for more everytime the credits
roll and with only six episodes in each
of the first two seasons and four in the
upcoming third season you can be sure
that not a minute goes to waste you can
still catch up on the first two seasons
before the third season shows up on
December 13th if you haven't clocked in
for kuku yet now's a good time to start
the show centers on a proper British
couple whose daughter just spent a year
abroad when they pick her up from the
airport they're dismayed to find that
she's returned with her lover a slacker
hippie played by Adam Samberg sorry it's
an honour can just a great great honor
after the first season however Samberg
left for other projects and was replaced
by American Werewolf in London Taylor
Lautner for the rest of the series
somehow it all ended up working and you
can check out the fourth season on
December 14th soon your body will be
butchered by extraterrestrial lasers but
our souls shall remain together through
cuckoo with narcos Netflix enthralled
the world with the story of DEA agent
Steve Murphy and his partner Javier Pena
as they worked to bring down the
notorious Pablo Escobar now a Netflix is
putting their true crime touch on the
tail with inside the Rio narcos as the
name suggests the docu-series will delve
into the real-life stories of drug
cartels in Latin America told through
interviews with real criminals it's sure
to be an engaging experience and you can
get your fix when inside the Rio narcos
drops on December 14th English comedian
Jimmy Carr hosts his upcoming comedy
panel show which sees a group of
comedians sitting down to solve some of
the social problems plaguing the world
each episode will see a different panel
of comedians tackling a different issue
lending their trademark wet to possible
solutions effective probably not but it
should be good for a laugh at the very
least tune in for the fix on December
14th novelist John Grisham carved out a
career with his numerous best-selling
courtroom thrillers
many of which have in turn been adapted
into blockbuster films he sold more
books about judges than the guy who
wrote the book of Judges with his 2006
book the innocent man however Grisham
took his time-tested formula and turned
it on its head writing a true crime
account instead of fiction a Netflix
adaptation will feature John Grisham and
will dig into the case through a series
of interviews with people who are
involved in the case look for it on
December 14th clearly Netflix has been
down under to pick up a ton of
Australian series but their upcoming
fantasy thriller tidelands marks the
streamer's first true Australian
original show tidelands sent us on a
criminal who heads home to a small
village on the Australian coast in
pursuit of a quiet life but she soon
finds that the town is secretly home to
a group of supernatural beings called
tide landers dive in on December 14th
Netflix hasn't been shy about showing
off their upcoming thriller bird box and
for good reason based on the 2014 book
of the same name bird box star Sandra
Bullock as Malory a new mother whose
world is turned topsy-turvy when people
begin taking their own lives in bizarre
ways it turns out there's some kind of
sinister force of work once you see it
you're driven to madness madness with a
premiere date of December 21st bird
boxes dark vision of the future will be
here just in time for Christmas
happy holidays Netflix's original
stand-up releases for December will be
arriving in two parts the first via das
losing it debuts on the 11th and Mark C
Indian comedians second special on the
server stars told Golf news that the new
special will touch on global events as
well as his personal life
the second stand-up special this month i
sees talk-show host Ellen DeGeneres
taking to the stage for the first time
in 15 years with a comedy set called
relatable take a look when it drops on
the 18th the holidays are arriving with
a bang this year as Netflix introduces a
handful of high-octane action movies
Movember sadly saw the removal of
Hellboy to the Golden Army but December
1st sees its predecessor 2004 tell boy
showing up also on the first look hell
for Terminator Salvation and a 1985
martial arts flick at the Last Dragon on
Christmas Day and Rapp Avengers infinity
war the first part of Marvel's epic
phase 3 combination the
the scrappy Avengers taking on the big
bad Titan Thanos he'll also find the
brand-new selection of dramatic films
landing this month such as 8 mile meet
Joe Black and 7 pounds all of which
arrived on the first after that the 16th
offers the chance to check out Eddie
Redmayne before he was news commander in
the theory of everything Redmayne stars
as Stephen Hawking in this hard-hitting
biopic about the acclaimed physicist
early years and his struggles to cope
with his gradual onset of Lou Gehrig's
disease there's an electric mix of
comedies hitting Netflix this December
but they all have one thing in common
they're hilarious what's the matter
David
I'm taking a shortcut before the Friday
trilogy hits Netflix on the first
alongside Shaun of the Dead The Big
Lebowski and the Bill Murray led spy
spoof the man who knew too little
finally tis the season for blood and
mayhem this Christmas the first of the
month sees the arrival of 1998 Bride of
Chucky John Carpenter's 1983 adaptation
of Stephen King's Christine and My
Bloody Valentine that cheesy 3d slasher
from 2009 about people throwing pickaxes
at you it'll be easier than ever to
binge brand new shows in the coming
month on the 3rd dive into blue planet -
the follow-up to the BBC's critically
acclaimed the nature series a sixth of
the month has seized the edition of the
first season of happy an offbeat sci-fi
series about a mentally imbalanced
hitman who becomes friends with his
daughter's imaginary unicorn based on
the graphic novel by Grant Morrison and
Derek Robertson happy is a visual treat
for anyone looking for a different sort
of comic-book hero
[Music]